i
hi how are you and greetings at 3 gonzález with
the brave training for june 30
a mother faces homicide charges
for the death of her 5 year old daughter who
was found dead in a house
near maryland parkway and cactus on tuesday
sources confirmed  that the minor died
after she was locked in a
room with no air conditioning a
2-year-old minor survived the incident and
is under the protection of the state
the mother that 23-year-old dorsal mesh and taylor will
appear in court on Thursday
the accused mother  of killing her children
samantha morenos rodriguez, 35,
appeared for the first time in court
this morning the prosecution revealed that
moreno rodriguez confessed to
strangling her 7-year-old son liam
husted and then naked on a trail
near mountain spring
the judge  samantha moreno denied bail
and will return to court on
August 3 at 10 in the morning
the hospital was a recent target of
cybercriminals the hospital first
noticed suspicious activity on their network
earlier this month but now says
hackers were able to access a
database however there is no evidence
they got into the clinical data system
the hospital had denied the
data breach but
now  the medical center confirms that it is
working with authorities to trace
the origin of the violation
the rain fell heavily in the town of
la genial according to reports
clark county firefighters responded to two
water rescues and reported
evacuations and power outages to the
national weather service  says that they have
received reports of the movement of
the moa to vale
and shelters are being prepared and sand is being bagged
let's go see the weather report the
clouds are still present in the valley of las
vegas' some drizzles were reported
in the morning and for the  rest of the day
there is a 30 percent chance
of more rain throughout the city
precipitation has cooled  do to the valley and
temperatures are expected to
reach 100 degrees for today is
all the information is reported by andrés
gonzález with about the
news now in spanish
[Music]